um they called 20 the year 2020 the year
of autocratization
um and so we're now in this period of of
democratic decline not just in kind of
fledgling democracies relatively new
democracies but for the first time we're
seeing the most liberal democracies like
the united states and the uk decline as
well yeah so that begs the question why
the heck did democratization peak and
then reverse well that's the
million-dollar question and everybody of
course would like to answer that
um the biggest theory out there
is it has something to do with the rise
of the internet and social and
unregulated social media wow
and if you look
which regions for example
had democratic decline last
um it correlates with internet
penetration
so as internet the internet penetrated
different regions of the world they
penetrated the wealthier regions first
and uh in countries where people relied
most heavily
on on social media in particular
facebook for their
news source their main news source
that's where you began to see
democracies weaken and people's trust
and democracy declined
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward
best-selling author of how civil wars
start and how to stop them political
science professor barbara walter joins
forward to talk her new book
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
forward podcast the new york times
bestselling author of how civil wars
start and how to stop them
professor at uc san diego barbara walter
welcome barbara
thank you for having me it's really a
pleasure to be here you have been making
the rounds this book has definitely
struck a chord how has your experience
been talking to people about it are
folks receptive are they like yes this
is totally something to be concerned
about has there been uh an ideological
breadth
or a variance in terms of how people
respond to your book
so i've been spending the last three
years alone in a dark office
not really talking to anybody just just
typing away and anybody who's written a
book knows that as you're doing this you
you really have no idea what the
reception is going to be especially when
you're somebody like me who's an unknown
academic a social scientist an egghead
who's writing on a really tough
um frightening subject you know the
assumption is is
is probably that that nobody's going to
want to read it and and so when it when
i started it started to gain attention
before it was even released i was
surprised and then of course it just
exploded and
and that's fantastic i was hoping the
message would get out there but it's
completely unexpected and and then when
it started to blow up i really was
worried um about the reception would it
be positive would it be negative would i
get a lot of death threats
and really until yesterday it was
unbelievably positive and that gave me
such hope um for you know where america
is today so not only were people you
know
open to the idea they wanted this
information they were engaging with the
information
but they i got hundreds and hundreds of
emails just thanking me for for writing
it and the and then the message i was
getting was was very consistent it was
you know americans who love their
country who who feel like something's
going wrong who feel like something's
building but they don't really
understand it they don't really know how
to think about it and they all said you
know the book just gave them a framework
for
for beginning to understand it was
excellent at providing a framework which
i enjoyed as a math guy there were
numerical scales for everything so when
you said until yesterday
you know i i really kind of thought i
was in the safe zone you know this is
three months into the the media
blitz and and it's been so positive and
then yesterday afternoon i just started
getting emails more emails than i've
gotten on any single day
and it was overwhelmingly
negative a lot of it was um very
personal attacks a lot of it was um
just diatribes about the left
um
and i and
some of it were death threats and and it
was for the the first time since the
book was released that i was actually a
little bit scared where i thought this
is
you know this is not good but and i
didn't understand why it was happening
um i had done an interview a few weeks
ago with the washington post um and the
washington post published that interview
yesterday but i've there's been lots of
articles in the washington post i've
published there myself
it's never elicited this response and
then i realized that all the emails were
coming from people who um read the the
interview not at the washington post but
on yahoo news
and and so it was so interesting that
this one
media venue um was hitting a very
different type of audience um that was
incredibly angry um uh they hadn't read
the book uh and they they were angry at
the interview they were angry about what
i said and then i went back and read the
interview just to make sure that there
wasn't anything that i had said that was
twisted or or
um
and and it was
it was
not it was a very reasonable
interview where i talked about many of
the things i talked about in the book um
i was careful not to not to you know be
alarmist and it just had this completely
different reaction with this particular
audience well that was my immediate
response when you described that
scenario which is oh what happened was
it got published to
a generally conservative right-leaning
audience who took on bridge uh and it
it's it's an experience i've had in
different ways you know like you speak
to the same message to different groups
and you get a very very different
response
now this is not something that you just
studied for this book you literally
spent
decades
studying civil wars uh including
in
africa in asia you've personally
been in dangerous situations how the
heck does one embark on that as an
academic career so it's doubly
interesting because my parents were
immigrants and my mother came from
switzerland which is this neutral
country
um a peace-loving country and and that
really has informed all of my research
i'm i went to graduate school i started
studying civil wars because the thing i
care about the most is peace
that's what i want that's the problem
that i want to solve and the reason i
studied civil wars as opposed to
interstate wars is that um civil wars
actually kill significantly more people
on average than interstate wars they
last significantly longer than
interstate wars they are much much
harder to end which once they start
um and unlike interstate wars they are
tend to be fought to the death they
don't tend to end in negotiated
settlements so so as somebody who's
whose main mission is to reduce violence
in the world um i gravitated towards
civil war because they are
um one of the the biggest problems we
have related to violence um and that's
been true for the last hundred years you
got some new data about civil wars or i
suppose the entire field got some new
data about civil wars um relatively
recently i think there was a sense that
democracy was winning uh for a
particular period of time and then
over the last
gosh
to 20 years or so it seems like it's
been backsliding the other direction
so big picture is that correct uh and
what was this new data set that you and
other researchers recently had access to
in terms of civil conflicts one of the
amazing things about um the study of
civil wars is that there's so much data
that we have on it on everything from
why they start to why they last as long
as they last
who gets targeted what are the goals how
many people get killed
and in order to understand those big
patterns
people have been collecting data on
everything that they think could
influence civil wars and of course one
of the things that people have thought
could influence civil wars is the type
of government that countries have in
place
you know whether it matters that you're
a democracy or an autocracy or you're
something in between and there's
actually at least five big non-profit
organizations around the world that
collect data on countries and measure
how democratic or autocratic they are
and they do this every year and it goes
back some of them go back to the late
1700s so we have this wealth of data
and all of those
data sets have been showing
two big patterns the first is that the
20th century was the the century of
democrat democratization
it was this
it was amazing how democracy was was
growing and spreading around the world
at the beginning of the 1900s
there were very few democracies around
the world and by the end of the 1900s a
majority of countries were democratic
and it showed no
indication that this was going to
reverse and and all of us who studied
democracy were incredibly hopeful we we
thought oh all we have to do is wait
as countries become wealthier
their citizens are going to demand war
rights and eventually all countries in
the world will be democratic
and then it ended 2010 was the peak of
democracy around the world and since
2010
the number of democracies in every
region
has been consistently declining and
that's been happening every single year
to the point where one of the big
organizations that measures democracy
it's called
v-dem it's a swedish organization
they called 20 the year 2020 the year of
autocratization
and so we're now in this period of of
democratic decline not just in kind of
fledgling democracies relatively new
democracies but for the first time we're
seeing the most liberal democracies like
the united states and the uk decline as
well yeah so that begs the question why
the heck did democratization peak and
then reverse well that's the million
dollar question and everybody of course
um would like to answer that
um the biggest theory out there
is it has something to do with the rise
of the internet and social
and unregulated social media wow
and if you look um if you look to see
which regions for example
had democratic decline last
um it correlates with internet
penetration um
so as internet the internet penetrated
different regions of the world they
penetrated the wealthier regions first
and
it in countries where people relied most
heavily on on social media in particular
facebook for their news source their
main news source
that's where you began to see
democracies weaken and people's trust
and democracy decline
the most interesting case is africa
africa
as a continent continued to democratize
until 2019. that was after every other
continent was ex was experiencing
democratic decline and everyone was sort
of scratching their heads
africa is not known uh to be
you know a continent where democracies
have an easy time growing and yet it was
persevering there in a way that it
wasn't persevering anywhere else
and if you looked at um at countries
with the lowest internet penetration
rate um north korea is the the
is is the last country it has the least
internet penetration and the next 10
countries are all in africa so africa
was insulated
from
from social media as a tool by which
anti-democratic
players want to be autocrats
could begin to slowly
gain support and and then once you had a
majority of people
getting their news from social media on
that continent
starting in 2019 you started to see
democratic decline there as well again
we don't have solid evidence for this um
that's there that's um
people who study this that's their main
hunch
and it is one of the reasons why
scholars have been pushing
very very hard for for companies like
facebook to
release their data to make their data
transparent because until they do that
we we have no hard evidence
that social media and in particular the
recommendation engines that are that are
pushing particularly incendiary material
are driving a whole host of negative
societal outcomes it sounds like there's
a remote village somewhere that doesn't
have internet that's a thriving
democracy
that's what it sounds like oh i wish it
was that easy right
it's more complicated than that but but
that you know unregulated social media
makes it easy for
for those who want to undercut democracy
and putin's been a master of this um
throughout central western europe the
united states
he was involved in the brexit debate um
you know the cia revealed that he was he
had meddled in our 2016 elections it is
his main tool um for weakening liberal
democracies which he sees as his main
enemy well it makes sense to people it
sounds like there's a statistical
correlation but it also makes sense that
the decline of institutional trust would
go hand in hand with social media and
internet adoption spiking because then
you can have any point of view any
conspiracy theorist and the more
incendiary your point of view that the
more likely you are to gain attention
because of the algorithms uh so let let
me just say that relationship makes
perfect sense to me and it probably
makes perfect sense to most people
uh watching or listening to this
uh that we imagine that the internet
would be a positive force for democracy
but it looks like it has been the
opposite yes and and you know i i
everybody was was
was thrilled with internet initially in
terms of of you know what people were
calling people power that it was going
to make it easier for citizens to
organize um to have their voices heard
if if they were unhappy with their
government and they wanted to mobilize a
peaceful protest the internet makes it
easy to do that
but if
but at the time um we didn't know that
things like the like button and the
share button were going to be
invented we didn't know that
recommendation engines were going to be
designed
with with the goal of maximizing
people's engagement online their time
online we didn't know that the material
that human beings because of the way our
brains are wired
that human beings would spend much more
time on the more negative information
the more
emotive information that that that
created feelings of rage um and and hate
and fear um
people engage with that
material far more than than material
that is calming and and and that makes
you feel
feel happy and good
and and because of that they get fed
more and more of that material and and
and that has the effect of of
heightening tensions heightening fear
and dividing societies and of course we
didn't know this at the beginning of the
internet because the internet wasn't
originally it didn't have these features
well in your book you point out that
this is a product of the business model
which is maximizing engagement and ad
revenue
uh and that also is something that i
think most people here sense and live
every day
you know in the press they talk about
small businesses and how we have to
protect small businesses and it's
annoying because
nothing about
our business or most people who own a
small business nothing about that feels
small a small business can be millions
of dollars in revenue and when you're
running a small business time is money
which is why i want to talk to you guys
about stamps.com because stamps.com
saves us money all the time you don't
waste time with either repeated trips to
the post office or waiting in line or
skipping the nonsense it lets you print
official postage right from your
computer and saves you money in the
process so you can spend less time at
the post office and more time making
your customers happy which is why we
love it for more than 20 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses like ours so
whether you're sending invoices or you
got a side hustle etsy shop or a
full-blown warehouse shipping out orders
stamps.com will make your life easier
you just go online print out your stamps
when you need to mail something and bang
you can take care of all your shipping
needs without having to go to the post
office so we want you to stop overpaying
for shipping with stamps.com sign up
with promo code yang for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and a digital scale with no
long-term commitments or contracts so
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code yang check it out guys i
think you'll like it
[Music]
so you talk about
autocracies and democracies and i love
this because you had a numerical scale
that you didn't invent or devise is the
polity scale
uh but it's minus 10 to 10 with -10
being complete autocracy so that's north
korea
and then you have plus 10 is pure
democracy so that's
uh canada or sweden or something along
those lines yeah now america was a plus
10 until relatively recently so what the
heck happened
the polity scale is really important
because um i worked on this task force
run by the us government from 2017 to
the end of 2021
and our job was to come up with this
predictive model that helped um where
else will there be conflict not here but
where else well we were absolutely not
allowed to look at the united states
that was for boaten but um we looked
everywhere else and and we discovered
that countries that had two features um
were
were at high risk of civil war um if
they if those features continued and one
was enocracy which came from the polity
scale and enocracy are our governments
that are neither fully democratic nor
fully autocratic they're actually
between negative five on the polity
scale and positive five so they're this
middle zone
and what we discovered was that full
democracies this you know the swedens
and the canadas they almost never
experienced civil wars and full
autocracies the north koreas and the
saudi arabias rarely experience civil
wars the violence happens uh almost
always in this middle zone so the middle
this middle zone is the danger zone for
for reasons you know that we could talk
about if people are interested but but
it's important to know um that that
that's where the violence and the
political instability
happens um
and the united states as you said andrew
was a positive 10 for much of its
history and then
in 2016 uh the non-profit organization
that that runs the polity scale that
that measures um how democratic or or
authoritarian a country is every year
they downgraded the united states from a
positive 10 to a positive eight
and they did that for a number of
reasons but the one of the more
important reasons was that international
election observers who were here in 2016
to observe our elections they deemed it
free but not entirely fair
and it wasn't entirely fair in part
because of partisan meddling
at the local level
in terms of of
voting
but also because
you know the cia our intelligence
agencies had discovered uh that russia
had successfully meddled
via the internet via disinformation
campaigns in the elections as well
and so we were downgraded to positive
eight
the the center for systemic peace
downgraded the united states once again
in
2019
and it did this because
we had a president and an executive
branch that was refusing to respond
to demands for information from congress
and refused to respond to subpoenas and
that might not seem like a big deal but
the way our founding fathers designed
our democracy
was um
through a series of checks and balances
and the main check on presidential power
the main check on the executive branch
is the legislative branch and if you
have an executive branch and a president
who refuses to comply with any requests
or demands by the main check on its
power then that indicates that the
executive branch is significantly more
powerful and is essentially running
roughshod
over the legislature
and so we were downgraded again and then
by the end of the trump administration
by the end of 2020 we were downgraded to
a positive five um and that's the first
time the united states was there since
1800 and that meant that the united
states by this measure
was considered an anocracy um uh and so
in in by the end of 2020 the u.s lost
its position as the world's longest
standing democracy previous to that we
were the oldest democracy in the world
and now that honor goes to switzerland
and the reason that um the u.s was
downgraded at the end of 2020 was
because we had a sitting president again
in the executive branch which is now
more powerful than any other branch we
had a president who was refusing to
accept the results of an election and
was actively trying to overturn it
so that's where we're at the end of 2020
we are now back at a positive eight um
we got upgraded but not to a positive
ten we got upgraded
when there was actually a peaceful
transfer of power
and when the new president um
uh was showed that he was going to
follow the rule of law so that's where
we are today so the danger zone by this
scale is between plus five and minus
five yeah uh and and i think a lot of
people don't believe that this
particular
storm has passed uh at this point 65
percent of republicans
believe that the last election was not
legitimate uh that's about 30 percent of
the population
um so
the studies uh around cause of conflict
uh i found this fascinating a lot of
people know i ran for president uh and
one of the well they know i ran for
president but they know i went for
president on this idea of a transforming
economy
and that the
economic
uh forces were going to push and are
have already pushed many many americans
to the sidelines and i believe that this
was going to be something that was uh
going to lead to all sorts of political
and social ills
uh now your
data shows that uh that is something of
a precondition where if if people are
emirated uh then uh it can lead to
conflict but that that poverty is not
the main factor though nor is even
inequality which i think is going to be
counterintuitive to a lot of people
because that that's what you imagine uh
is a precursor to conflict
um instead you pose that uh it's the
formation of factions what what do you
mean by that yeah so i mentioned earlier
that the task force found that two two
factors in particular were highly
predictive the first was whether a
country
where whether a country's government was
an anocracy or not and the second factor
was
whether in those
anocracies citizens had organized
themselves
into political parties that were based
on ethnicity religion or race as opposed
to any political ideology so you didn't
have socialist parties and liberal
parties you you had a serb party a croat
party or a muslim party in a christian
party
um
those were the countries that were
particularly combustible um and those
those types of parties um
um
tended to want to rule to the exclusion
of of everyone else so we called them
predatory parties they they organized
along identity and then they sought to
gain political power not only to rule
but to shut everybody else out of power
and so in some ways they were
anti-democratic parties and we know
um you know we know that one of the
motivations for groups to want to rebel
is if they feel they are
shut out of power so it's political
exclusion that really motivates people
much more than poverty or inequality and
actually it makes sense
because you can be poor but if your
group has political representation you
have an avenue by which you can help
improve your group situation i'm not
saying that it's like it's always
successful but you have a political
avenue for change
if you're politically excluded from
power and and you're poor there's
nothing you can do
to at least within conventional politics
to improve your lot and so it's those
groups that that sometimes turn
um to to violence as as a means of
affecting change so so it's this notion
that that there's no way you're ever
going to have representation in power um
that that really seems to galvanize
people to organize and to turn to
violence
so a faction along ethnic lines is the
most dangerous uh and in your book you
talk about yugoslavia and other
societies that have experienced a
version of this uh you refer to
a political leader who activates this
kind of party as an ethnic entrepreneur
which i found fascinating um that's
probably a term of art where this this
isn't something that
that
uh that you you came up with
but but you described trump as in in
many ways the ultimate ethnic
entrepreneur yeah yeah so ethnic
entrepreneur is an old political science
term um and it you it refers to
individuals and they're usually
politicians but they can be business
leaders they can actually be
church leaders they can be internet
personalities
but usually you see
ethnic entrepreneurs emerge
in politics and
the term exists because you have these
individuals who at certain times um and
it's usually times of transition when
when uh citizens are going through
usually
some sort of
change and it could be a demographic
change it could be you know an economic
crisis it could be a technological
transformation so times of change
tend to make average citizens um
uncertain
feel they tends to make them feel a
little bit insecure
and that's actually fine people can
weather these these times we've all gone
through them ourselves
but ethnic entrepreneurs are individuals
who see these times as opportunities for
them to
try to grab political power by preying
on this fear and and insecurity and they
often use ethnicity as a way to
galvanize support and i think the best
way to illustrate this is to talk about
um you know one of the classic ethic
entrepreneurs who is slobodan milosevic
he was an old-time communist in the form
of yugoslavia he'd been a member of the
communist party he'd been in power
because he was a good communist and then
the soviet union collapsed and
yugoslavia was allowed to pick whatever
political system it had and yugoslav's
citizens decided that they wanted to
democratize and they very quickly
organized
real competitive elections and here you
have milosevic who very much wants to
stay in power
but he knows that yugoslavs don't like
communists and they know and he knows
that they know that he's a communist and
so if he runs as a communist there's no
way he's going to win
that he's going to be able to compete
effectively so he's very savvy and he's
very strategic and he realizes that the
biggest ethnic group in yugoslavia
are the serbs they had the greatest
numbers and he was a serb so he began to
just
pump out this narrative he controlled he
was able to control state radio he was
able to control state television and he
continuously
broadcast this message
that during these uncertain times serbs
had to band together
and they had to form their own party and
they had to follow a strong serb leader
because if they didn't do that the
croats were going to do that and if the
croats did that and they they got into
power instead of the serbs then they
were going to kick serbs out of their
jobs kick them out of the military and
possibly kill them like some crowets had
done during world war ii and this
message
really resonated during this time when
when yugoslavs were when were were
looking around and and not really sure
how how this new state was going to
play out and they were
worried and they followed milosevic and
he understood
that that that playing on ethnicity and
identity and people's
fear and insecurity
could be a powerful motivator for them
to get behind him and that's really what
an ethnic entrepreneur is
yeah and that wound up in a
conflagration of uh
of tragic and terrible proportions
uh with uh
you know yugoslavia being torn apart by
civil war and uh
uh was that
termed a genocide or ethnic cleansing it
was the first time the term ethnic
cleansing was used and it was a
conscious policy by the serbs the croats
did it to a certain extent as well but
but the serbs did it
more widely
their goal was to
move croats out of serb areas and then
especially in in bosnia herzegovina
where you had a large
croat and muslim population
to especially move
the muslims out
both by killing them
and by
chasing them out of the region and and
forcing them to flee and of course most
of them never returned um and so it was
a success
successful strategy of radically
changing the demographics
of certain regions of that country
[Music]
so a faction along ethnic lines is
particularly dangerous uh and sometimes
it can be combined with other
factors like where people live to form a
superfaction and one of the consistent
threads in yugoslavia and other places
is an urban rural divide
so here in the us it obviously calls to
mind
rural whites uh lining up behind donald
trump
as
uh super faction if you will yeah so the
more types of identities or or
i don't want to say
um a line in one party um the in some
ways the more dangerous it is and so
super factions are particularly
dangerous and and it's when you have a
party based on race or ethnicity but
also based on the same religion and then
also based on the same geographic
location um and in serbia you had um you
know they were you know the the third
party was was all serbs um they were all
um the particular type of christianity
that serbs were
and they were all predominantly uh rural
dwellers not not city dwellers um and um
and and they were the ones who then went
after
um the the more urban uh
you know first they went after the
bosnian muslims and then then they or
well actually creation they went after
the croatians first and then in bosnia
bosnia they went after the bosnian
muslims first um who are predominantly
living in the cities like sarajevo
so i i have to say this narrative uh
definitely leads one to very dark
parallels uh in in terms of the us uh
you know another factor that you cite
current uh that recurs
globally is a loss of status where you
feel like you were
on the
inside and then you're on the outside
either politically or culturally or
economically yeah so you know the whole
reason i wrote this book was was you
know i'm on this task force i'm sitting
in
different conference rooms outside of dc
we're talking about all these countries
around the world we know what the model
predicts we know that the model is
actually quite good at predicting where
instability and violence is and and i'm
seeing the same factors emerge here in
the united states and it was shocking to
to me to see so many parallels you know
we've been talking about ethnic
entrepreneurs long before donald trump
emerged and of course he is also a
classic
ethnic entrepreneur we also know who
tends to start these um
ethnic civil wars and we have there's an
old term for that as well we call them
sons of the soil
and sons of the soil are groups
um and they can they can be uh the you
know the dominant group in a country as
a whole or they could be the dominant
group in a region but sons of the soil
are are ethnic groups
that
believe that they are
the the
rightful heirs
to
a country they believe that um the
identity of the that that the identity
of the country should reflect their
ethnicity their religion they believe
that they should always be in power
because they had been in power they are
in power or had been in power in the
past um and they're the ones who tend to
start civil wars if they see their grip
on power
um fading or if they actually lose
um
their majority status because
demographics have have changed and and
what seems to be motivating them again
it's not poverty these these ten these
are not the poorest groups in society
but it's this deep
sense of um resentment at the loss of
status
where they they truly believe this is
our country we deserve to be in power in
our country nobody's going to take that
away from us and and we're going to
fight for our country and it's it's our
right and it's our duty to do that and
so you know i've studied signs of the
soil for for decades and and then you
know january 6th happen and and you're
watching you're watching the same
um
the same feelings um being broadcast
here were you know mostly white men um
marching with impunity down the mall
taking videos of themselves breaking
into the capital
and they truly believed that they were
being patriots um you know they did not
think what they were doing was illegal
they certainly didn't think it was
potentially treasonous they thought it
was their
um their duty to take their country back
and that is a classic
sons of the soil
feeling
and and it's if they're unsuccessful
in taking their country back um then um
the more extreme elements of those sons
of the soil group um you know often
organize and they're the ones who start
these wars
uh so there is a scale for factionalism
as well i was thrilled to see it uh
apparently it's a five-point scale and
right now the united states is at a
three is that accurate yeah and three is
where
three indicates that you have um ethnic
factions yes there's also and this is a
very dark thing but i believe it's
something like a
violence or genocide scale
which is a 10-point scale and on that
the united states is at roughly a five
is that correct yes yes um and uh you
know these are out there your listeners
can can google um all of this and it's
all public access and they can read
about it but um
you know what's so surprising when you
read this
the ten steps to genocide um
is um first how the early the early
steps
you know
could appear quite innocent
so that people really don't know that
they're moving up the steps as it's
happening and you've probably heard the
analogy that people have been been using
and they use this oftentimes with the
rise of fascism it's it's like the frog
and the water right um
where somebody turns up the heat and and
you know the frog doesn't even realize
that things are getting worse um until
it's until it's too late um and it's
it's oftentimes similar with ethnic
cleansing or genocide that the early
stages of it seem
um quite innocent and oftentimes it's
portrayed to the public as these are
necessary steps that need to be taken to
protect people right so one of the steps
is is identification where people are
you know are asked to have ident id
cards um and you know people are told
this is really this is to protect you um
and so people get id cards but of course
one of the reasons why id cards um or or
why why um
leaders will want people to have id
cards is if it's actually difficult to
determine who is a serb or who is a
croat or who is a jew and who's a german
this is exactly what happened in rwanda
prior to the genocide there where
tootsies and hutus are indistinguishable
you cannot tell
um the the difference and in fact
they're ethnically the same
and so if you're a hutu and you are
losing power which is what was happening
in rwanda and you want to prevent tutsis
from coming to power and and you know
extremists in the hutu party they were
called the interhom way
um they're the ones who organize the
genocide but one of the things they have
to do is try to figure out who the
tutsis are and so so
years before they required everybody to
have id cards that that then
could tell them um who who was tootsie
and who was hutu so that's just an
example of and you know these it
seemingly innocent measures
that slowly build over time until you
know suddenly people are in a situation
where where they're convinced that the
ot well the other side is
is almost sub-human and certainly a
threat to them and and is a threat to
the state and and needs to be either
deported or imprisoned or you know the
extreme case would be
killed
[Music]
uh so you point out that there are
uh extremists on both sides but that the
vast majority of the violence comes from
people associated with the alt-right i
think the percentage was something
around 80 percent or four to one
uh
which
i think most people sense uh that that
uh that there's a higher
propensity for instigation and violence
uh from
the right and you you do paint a picture
about what a civil war
could
look like in the united states uh which
would not be a civil war in a
conventional sense where you have
political
uh entities and conventional warfare but
instead you have dozens or hundreds of
militias
engaging in what most people would
consider terrorist activities uh how
many militias are there right now in the
u.s i think there's over 400 um
so we we were at a peak previously in
1996 um and that's the year that timothy
mcfay bombed the federal building in
oklahoma city um militias had been
growing um prior to that and then they
declined after oklahoma city and they
declined because the fbi was quite uh
effective at going after these groups
and um
and imprisoning their leaders and
infiltrating them but also in part
because i think america the american
public was so disgusted by what they saw
that if these these far-right groups had
or these militias had a hard time
recruiting that shifted in 2008 since
2008 we've seen once again um the rise
in a rapid rise of militias most of it's
been on the far right uh of the vast
majority or i think about 65 percent of
those far-right groups are white
supremacist groups about 25 percent or
anti-federal government groups there's
some overlap between the two but that's
what we're seeing on the far right
now i get a lot of emails from people
saying well what about the far left and
what about antifa
you know is you know are you being
biased by only showcasing the right
um and
my response to that is you know there's
great data on militias um and we
actually know that far left um
militias
were the majority in the in the 60s and
70s so you could think about the black
panthers you could think about
violent environmentalist groups
anarchists
so it was the left
in previous decades that was
that was dominant
they have been declining
and the far right has been growing to
the point where um you know most of the
the violent extremists here in the
united states are definitely on on the
far right antifa exists um
uh but it's it's one
group it's it's
small and and again in terms of of
numbers the numbers of of militias on
the far right is much greater
so you paint a daunting picture uh
people are now picking up on it um in
the mainstream and we all owe you a debt
uh when you started your book you didn't
know that events would then end up
essentially verifying
uh your thesis
uh
so you do suggest some solutions one of
the facts in your book that really
struck me
uh is that of the
civil
wars that occurred in democracies over a
multi-decade period uh none of them were
in proportional democracies they were
all in majoritarian
uh or presidential systems uh which the
us has
and
you
present and i think this is correct is
that look people may go through the
political system unless they feel like
there's just no hope for them um and
i'm not sure if you you know but i've
started
uh the forward party to try to shift us
towards a more
dynamic representative uh multi multi
democracy which i i think is a must
uh
what solutions
uh do you think are most vital for us to
try and make progress on
uh
in the time we have because i you know
people also know that i'm very i think
trump runs again in 24 i think he wins
the republican nomination i think he uh
he is a very very strong bet to win
outright um or if he doesn't win
outright
say he won and then uh you know we'll
see
uh a replay of january 6 but on a larger
scale
um
so i i suppose i just double down on the
very uh you know dark picture that that
you painted in your book
um so
what are the things that you are most
animated about in terms of solutions it
sounds like one of them is social media
for sure well that would be the easiest
solution
you know we the us government regulates
all sorts of industries that we know
could potentially harm american citizens
we
regulate the meat industry we regulate
mainstream media television and radio
so we understand
how powerful
a tool media can be and how it could be
used um to really tear societies apart
and and yet here we have this enormous
um
uh media vehicle that is is now
dominating everything else it's bigger
than any traditional media vehicle at
this point most people are getting their
news and there's no regulation
and i actually am not
somebody who advocates censoring
um what people put on uh social media
platforms i think people
for the most part should be allowed to
put whatever they want on these
platforms free speech go for it what i
what i don't believe should be allowed
is for social media companies to take
again the the most divisive the most
extreme the most um
you know incendiary material and give it
an enormous audience instantaneously and
mag and basically be a megaphone for
that information because they know that
that information keeps people engaged
and keeps them coming back more than
information that would be helpful to
society and um so the fact that that
that they're allowed to do this and and
that there there's no restrictions and
we're and we're now in 2022 seeing you
know many of of the negative effects
there's all of these trends that have
emerged um since around you know the
late 2000s since you know 2010 the
decline of liberal democracy the rise of
ethnic nationalism the rise
of of hate crimes the rise of of um
far-right um
extremist groups um the rise of a
militias like all of these things are
happening at this particular moment in
time and you have to ask yourself
like
what is causing it and why is it
happening now what has changed to make
this possible and and
you know
everybody keeps gravitating back the
answer is social media and and you know
the fact that
that there there are no regulations on
this despite these really awful outcomes
is really um shocking it would be at the
five biggest tech companies are here in
the united states um it would be easy
for us to to tamp down this this
negative uh bull horn
well it'd be easy of us if our
government was
not
decades behind uh uh the
technological understanding curve uh you
know uh i mean right now even when they
do have hearings on it they berate the
tech leaders about uh issues that strike
me as marginal i mean like that like
like like the central problem is that
they're profiting to the tune of
billions of dollars by an algorithm that
uh accelerates hatefulness uh anger fear
resentment and oh by the way it's
uniquely subject to foreign
misinformation yes it's it's the
backdoor way
that our enemies can undercut our own
society it's you know they can't take on
the us military um you know it's hard to
infiltrate the united states in other
ways but boy it's really easy via the
internet via social media now you also
recommend i agree with this i agree with
just about everything you you uh
prescribe
um that our government has to do better
at delivering benefits to various folks
and you suggest things like maybe
healthcare
maybe
maybe something that they know
um that that uh you know is a win for
them um i like cash
that's one of my preferred mediums um
and you you describe this as out bidding
which i found to be a really interesting
frame it was like a political science
term um but that when
people are incited to violence uh
there's like a a bid for their loyalty
from
uh extremist groups uh or from ethnic
entrepreneurs or whatever and and and
you suggest look the government can
outbid
these other groups yeah um yeah so you
know we didn't have an ethnic faction in
this country
really until recently um you know
america didn't have racially based
parties um as late as 2008 white
americans were equally likely to vote
for democrats as they were to vote for
republicans
but that changed when barack obama came
to power and that's when the white
working class
and that group had traditionally been
supporters of the democratic party and
they supported the democratic party
because the democrats the social and the
economic policies
were more aligned with working-class
interests than the republican party's
policies um and they began to gravitate
towards the republican party because the
republican party was offering other
things um they were
they were using cultural issues they
were
playing on on you know fears of of you
know changing demographics so they were
offering other things to the white
working class and then the question is
okay why were they able to do this and i
think one of the answers is
um that both the republican party but
but the democratic party um
also um
they
in some ways didn't protect the white
working class from the negative effects
of globalization you know bill clinton
signed nafta
nafta that that
you know on average
helped um uh you know americans but
there were losers in in in nafta here in
the united states and that was you know
mostly white working-class men
who who used to have good union jobs um
that you know allowed them to lead um
solid middle-class lives
and then those manufacturing jobs left
um you know the democrats didn't put in
place
um you know a safety net to help that
group um and in fact the you know the
both parties have been
have been you know reducing social
services over time um to
middle class working class um and poor
americans um and and so there are real
grievances out there
but when you think of the sons of the
soil
and these are this is groups that had
once
been dominant politically and
economically these are these are groups
who who enjoyed lots of privileges um
who who are then seeing that their
status
is declining relative to other groups i
think i think that's what happened they
or on an absolute scale because you know
their life expectancy is diminishing you
know that's not relative that's uh yeah
you know their their divorce rates are
increasing you know they're they're less
likely to own homes and there's a whole
series of social indicators where they
have declined and latinos and
um and
african americans for example um you
know at worst they've remained steady
and so that that is you know building
resentment you know why are we doing
why are we doing worse when in fact we
should be doing better than everybody
and and that's where that you know this
this deep sort of anger and resentment
comes from
[Music]
uh so you don't say this in the book um
but i'm i'm curious what you think and
i'll just tell you what you know my
thoughts on this um
i ran for president and one of the
things i found is that our two-party
system is a really really poor
uh
a poor system for
different points of view
of
being
uh considered and then
uh it overcompensates in the sense that
if you do have one major party let's say
the republican party uh let's succumb to
bad leadership then all of a sudden you
can slump into authoritarianism very
very quickly
i i think the duopoly is the worst
design
failure in the history of the world and
that we we may end up suffering the
results uh do you think that if you had
and your research suggests that this is
the case that if you had a
representational system
then there's a lower propensity to
conflict because people would then have
like a a party that would represent
their point of view as opposed to some
some
right now you're trying to wedge
yourself into the two-party system and
sometimes that doesn't work or sometimes
you end up uh
dominating and i don't think either of
those is is positive yeah so yes i think
it would be more representative there
in the things you want to you want to
avoid when you set up your parliamentary
system one of the decisions you're going
to have to make is um you know
what percent of the vote do you need to
get a seat in parliament and you could
require that you win 10 of the vote
whatever
israel had one of the smallest
percentages i think it originally
started with you only needed one percent
and then they moved it to two percent
and wow it's quite small
and that actually
can lead to a tyranny of the minority
because if no if there are now so many
parties in parliament or that that no
one party can can you know win an
outright majority and therefore has to
form a coalition
it means that you could be a teeny tiny
party
and if you help a larger party get over
50 you can hold that party hostage so so
you you'd want to think about that there
were very good reasons why the founding
father fathers created this two-party
system they were
no but i mean they they set up
mechanisms that would lead to a
two-party system but they were anti-yes
partisan uh you know these other things
i mean the bigger problem andrea you you
know this um
is that
our democracy has so many archaic
undemocratic
weird bizarre features that no other
healthy strong democracy has um the
electoral college like ask any any
person in you know who lives in europe
in denmark or or germany or france um
and you talk about the electoral system
their head begins to spin they're just
like what what is this
um you know we have we have the
filibuster we have um
exactly we
have gerrymandering we have an executive
you know you know that's more powerful
than every every other um branch so so
our democracy i think is uniquely
vulnerable
to
backsliding towards authoritarianism um
you know especially with this
presidential winner take all system that
that if you get into power
um you know the president with the help
of of members of his or her party in
congress can begin to
tamper with democracy
our democracy in ways that makes it
really hard for the opposition to ever
regain control and and in essence to
cement in
you know the president's party even if
it's a minority of of the population and
this is exactly of course what the
republicans
are seeking to do now now that they see
that increasingly they don't have the
votes to win in a majoritarian system
uh it's it's very it's a very dark time
uh and
one of the
tough part in my opinion of like the
flaws of this system is that the
presidential election ends up becoming
in some ways like the sole release valve
which is a terrible system
like that that's like exactly
the opposite of what you'd want you you
know you'd want differences to be sorted
out well before then but let you know be
because of
a number of uh impediments like it's
very very hard for people to feel like
they're going to be able to make changes
in anything except us especially you
know now you have uh the filibuster
where um it's become impossible for
um either party really to get anything
done and what this does is it undercuts
um people's trust in democracy because
they see that nothing's getting done
they're seeing that nothing is being
reformed um and and and
cynicism begins to creep in and and
people begin to question whether in fact
this is the best system in the world and
then of course you have
you know
wannabe autocrats that who who would
prefer
um to have more power than less power
and and they continue that narrative you
know this the system isn't working or
um it's it's rigged against you um and
and
you know we need to to clean out the
swamp or whatever the euphemism
is but but trust in democracy and
support for democracy is declining
around the world including here in the
united states and
and one of the reasons why is is you
have you know a system that doesn't
appear to be able to to function
particularly effectively yes
uh you close your book on a personal
story that i i thought was very
uh brave of you to share honestly where
you and your
uh husband both children of immigrants
uh and you saw january 6 unfold and
you'd done the research you were doing
and you actually said you know what
maybe we should get passports to another
country like in case things start going
really south which you know i will say i
think a lot of americans have had those
thoughts
how are you feeling now and what are the
the thing i mean you've done dozens of
these interviews about your very very
successful and important book how civil
wars start um what have you
not had a chance to express in other
interviews like
that you know because i i feel like
um
and are is this
uh arc in
uh promoting the book is it making you
more optimistic or pessimistic
um it's
you know i i wasn't
i wasn't expecting
the hundreds of incredibly
kind positive supportive
grateful emails that i got and and these
emails
from thoughtful people who clearly love
this country and and want to do
everything they can
um to put it back on on the right course
and
um and that that gave me hope the the
emails from yesterday were were
disturbing
in part because
though the people who are writing those
seemed
unhinged in some ways sort of irrational
so incredibly angry
really not capable of of
communicating um beyond
there there's a lot of pain that is
manifesting itself in irrationality
and yeah and so you see this enormous
divide
um between
i don't know if it's a left right divide
but or or it's it's a division based on
education or i don't know what what that
the divide is
but
so i'm not really answering a question
let me how do i feel now no no i mean i
mean you know you just had this
experience very recently obviously
yesterday and as someone who has
received uh very very hateful negative
uh messages like it it's extraordinarily
difficult because you see it and you're
like wow
um
[Music]
and like that there is so much so much
yeah okay i guess that's the story i i
talk a little bit about in the book but
i i haven't really done it in interviews
i i grew up in just outside of new york
city in yonkers new york
but i've lived in california the last 25
years and i've lived in california
during its great transformation from a
state that was majority white to a state
that's minority white um and i teach at
a university that's 20 20 percent white
uh the vast majority of my students yeah
20 percent of my students are not are
not white
um and
and i've seen the trajectory and the
trajectory i think is a trajectory that
the rest of the country is going to go
through
and that trajectory is um you know as as
minorities here in california grew in
size the white majority or elements of
the white majority felt increasingly
threatened and you had an ethnic
entrepreneur
in the in the face of of um pete wilson
emerged to run to run for governor and
he ran on a very anti-immigrant
platform and he won on that platform he
he played towards the fears of whites
here in california about what would
happen to them and to their state if
immigrants continued to to
come into the
state and so he was his policies were
quite brutal towards um
towards mexicans in particular illegal
immigrants
he he uh wanted to withhold health care
for them education from them no driver's
license you know it was it was brutal
and he won the election
and then the latino population continued
to increase in california and became the
majority um and they never forgave him
and the republican party for those
brutal policies and and the reason why
california is such a solidly blue state
today is not because of of um
you know people like me it's it's
because of of latinos um
and and if you look to see how
california is doing today when we're on
the other side of this transition it's
thriving i i know the right likes to
portray it as as
having all sorts of of problems whether
it's homelessness or or other things
it's not a perfect state but our gdp has
has grown by 200 percent since um
uh since we've you know since the the
transition there's a whole host of
measures where where california is doing
um quite well and so when i think about
this
you know i think wow you know the other
end of this great transformation which
is going to happen by 2045 and the rest
of the united states the united states
will be
a white minority country by around 2045
and and whites are terrified or or a
subset of whites are terrified about
this but but i think what they need to
know is is wow you know we're we could
thrive um and and we could
uh as a as a you know a youthful dynamic
multicultural multi-religious country
um
you know be a model for the rest of the
world and of course the the rest of of
white majority countries are going to be
behind the united states we're going to
be the first country to go through this
transformation and so it really is
contingent on us
to show the rest of the world how we do
this because it's just it's going to
happen i could not agree with you more
that managing this transition is the
challenge of this generation and that if
we fail in it we will
uh fall
victim to some of the same conflicts
that have
plagued other societies i mean we're not
unique uh or or distinct
uh this is it this is what we have to do
together
uh thank you for such uh an important
contribution
how civil wars start and how to stop
them barbara walter newly minted new
york times bestselling author and uh
someone that we could all learn a lot
from i clearly have learned a lot from
uh both sitting with you and reading
this book so thank you
really was an honor to be able to have
this time with you thank you
oh the honor was all mine
[Music]
you